[Música]
y
ucrania entro en el cuarto mes de guerra
los ataques se intensifican en la región
del donbass la situación se complica
particularmente en lugares según el
gobernador el área enfrenta su peor
momento desde el estallido de la lucha
separatista en 2014
nuevo tiroteo mortal en eeuu 19 menores
y dos adultos de una escuela primaria en
texas perdieron la vida luego de que un
joven armado ingresara a la institución
el presunto atacante murió por disparos
de la policía el presidente joe biden
dijo que hay que actuar contra el lobby
de apps
en brasil 22 personas murieron tras una
redada policial en una favela de río de
janeiro el operativo tenía como objetivo
capturar a líderes de organizaciones
criminales escondidos allí el hecho
vuelve a poner en relieve el abuso de la
fuerza policial en esta zona del país
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz iniciamos en ucrania la
guerra cumplió tres meses desde que los
rusos iniciaron su ofensiva el pasado 24
de febrero actualmente el asedio de las
tropas del kremlin se concentra en la
región del donbass en el este del país
moscú intenta apoderarse de las
provincias de donges y lugansk y en este
último sólo faltan dos ciudades para que
los rusos lo controlen por completo que
son severo donges y liz y xiang el
ministerio de defensa ucraniano afirma
que allí se libra la fase más aguda del
conflicto mientras que el gobernador de
lugansk sostiene que enfrentan el
momento más difícil desde 2014 cuando
estalló la lucha de los separatistas pro
rusos y así lo reiteró el presidente
volodymyr select
la situación en done bass es
extremadamente difícil todo el poder
ruso que queda ahora se concentra en
esta región
liman pop asna severodonezk slomianski
los ocupantes quieren destruir todo allí
pero en sus intercepciones de
comunicación escuchamos claramente que
se dan cuenta de que esta guerra no
tiene sentido para ellos que
estratégicamente su ejército no tiene
ninguna posibilidad patrimonial
sin embargo requiere tiempo y un gran
esfuerzo sin precedentes de nuestro
pueblo para superar su ventaja en la
cantidad de equipo militar y armamentos
lo pasamos a eeuu porque se elevó a 21
el número de muertos tras un nuevo
tiroteo registrado este martes el hecho
se produjo en la ciudad de un baldío en
el estado de texas una comunidad con una
fuerte presencia latina cuando un joven
armado ingresó a la escuela primaria rob
y acabó con la vida de 19 menores y dos
adultos esto luego y el atacante murió
por los disparos de la policía este es
el tiroteo escolar más mortal registrado
en el estado luego de que otro joven
asesinar a 10 personas en la escuela
secundaria de santafé en 2018 el
presidente joe biden ordenó izar las
banderas a media asta y condenó estos
hechos que han venido repitiéndose en el
país
a
esta hora de que aquellos que obstruyen
o retrasan o bloquean las leyes de armas
de sentido común les hagamos saber que
no lo olvidaremos podemos hacer mucho
más tenemos que hacer más arte de humor
nuestra oración esta noche para esos
padres
acostados en la cama tratando de
averiguar
podré dormir de nuevo lo que
les digo a mis otros hijos qué pasará
mañana
y que dios bendiga la pérdida de vidas
inocentes en este triste día y que el
señor esté cerca de los quebrantados de
corazón y salve a los aplastados de
espíritu porque van a necesitar muchas
muchas de nuestras oraciones
bienvenido
que dios los ame
este martes al menos 22 personas
perdieron la vida en un operativo
antidroga en la favela vila cruzeiro en
río de janeiro el hecho ocurre justo un
año después de la matanza de 28
residentes de ella caras niño por parte
de uniformados desde entonces muchos han
denunciado abusos de la fuerza policial
especialmente contra los pobres
como en una película de terror a las 4
de la mañana los habitantes de la favela
vila cruzeiro río de janeiro se
despertaron con el sonido de un tiroteo
en un bosque pegado al asentamiento
fruto de un operativo policial en el que
buscaban a narcotraficantes que
supuestamente se escondían en la favela
del norte de la ciudad y que se saldó
con la vida de varios residentes
no creo que podamos normalizar que el
estado entre en una favela y deje 20
cadáveres o más no sabemos por qué
todavía tenemos que recuperar cuerpos
del bosque
hace poco más de tres meses en febrero
la policía ya mató a ocho personas
presuntamente involucradas en acciones
ilegales en vila cruzeiro y es que en
los cientos de favelas de río de janeiro
estas redadas son habituales y muchos
han tenido que enterrar a sus seres
queridos
no hay una justicia honesta y
lamentablemente los que sufrimos somos
nosotros la población en
este suceso se produce un año después de
la mayor matanza policial de río en la
favela jacarezinho que se saldó con la
vida de 28 personas desde entonces sólo
dos policías han sido procesados y diez
de las tres de investigaciones sobre
abuso policial han sido archivadas allí
la gente todavía vive con miedo
fue el zeta
pero la policía se creó para que nos
sintiéramos seguros pero lo que sentimos
es miedo porque cuando escuché la voz
dentro de la casa sentimos miedo
entramos en pánico porque escuchamos los
disparos los gritos como invadían las
casas
en su memoria en los vecinos del barrio
levantaron un muro azul con el nombre de
las víctimas pero la policía que a
partir de junio de 2020 ya no puede
llevar a cabo redadas sin informar al
ministerio público lo derribo por
supuesta apología al tráfico de drogas
guillermo lasso cumplió un año como
presidente de ecuador y ofreció un
discurso ante el congreso con el informe
de su gestión el mismo día en que la
nación celebró el bicentenario de su
independencia en los logros exhibidos
contrastaron con las críticas por parte
de organizaciones indígenas el
mandatario dedicó una importante parte
de su alocución a resaltar sus logros en
la lucha contra la pandemia de kobe 19 a
la que caracterizó como una hazaña
histórica con un 80 por ciento de la
población ecuatoriana vacunada con dos
dosis y también exhibió logros en
materia económica en esta línea destacó
el aumento del salario mínimo y la
reducción del desempleo juvenil entre
otros temas
la tasa de desempleo juvenil se ha
reducido del 13 6% en mayo del 2021
a 88 por ciento al primer trimestre del
2022 es decir cerca de 110 mil jóvenes
encontraron un empleo somos el segundo
país con la inflación más baja en
américa latina' de manera que en
muchísimo menos tiempo del previsto la
economía ecuatoriana ya inspira
confianza en el mundo y en actores
económicos generadores de inversión la
viruela del mono que comienza a ser un
tema de interés por su extraña aparición
en un brote fuera de áfrica puede ser
contenida con aislamiento de los casos
que han tenido contacto con los
infectados según las autoridades
sanitarias además hay una vacuna
desarrollada que puede ayudar a evitar
su expansión alemania y otros países
europeos toman medidas para que el virus
no siga propagándose para evitar la
expansión de casos de viruela del mono
alemán ya compra 40.000 dosis de una
vacuna existente a un laboratorio danés
para aplicarlas a personas que han
tenido contacto con infectados
la vacuna es sin duda un desarrollo
adicional de las vacunas convencionales
contra la viruela y está diseñada
específicamente para ser una alternativa
más segura la vacuna se originó en el
instituto estatal de baviera y se
desarrolló allí en las décadas de 1960 y
cuando la campaña de vacunación contra
la viruela original aún estaba en curso
la fuga en francia se vacunará a los
adultos en riesgo de contagio lo mismo
hará dinamarca las autoridades
sanitarias consideran que no ven posible
que haya una nueva pandemia y que el
brote puede contenerse la bebé se está
publicando orientaciones también sobre
las vacunas y las consideraciones de
inmunización pero lo más importante en
este momento es darse cuenta de que este
brote puede ser contenido debido al
rastreo de los contactos y al
aislamiento lado ms reporta más de 200
casos entre sospechosos y confirmados en
19 países la mayoría europeos los
síntomas de la enfermedad incluyen
fiebre inflamación de los nódulos
linfáticos dolores de cabeza cansancio
muscular
cutáneas la forma de contagio según las
investigaciones preliminares es por
contacto sexual estrecho e intercambio
de fluidos la viruela del mono que es
endémica en áfrica occidental desde hace
40 años y tiene una tasa de mortalidad
de alrededor del 1% fue contenida en el
continente durante la pandemia de kobe
19 hasta que este informativo gracias
por acompañarnos
[Música]